Here I am on the set of my new video for
anytime you need a friend dressed up
like a princess I guess or a queen
whatever yeah if this video doesn't look
familiar it's because it never got
released but now et is opening the MC
vault revealing this rare footage from
the set
[Music]
the year was 1994 Mariah was newly
married to Tommy Mottola the head of her
record label Sony Music and privately
fighting a battle over her image come
here this is the director Diane tell
what are these what's the what is the
concept of this video because I don't
even know it's better concept what is
the concept we're making special oh yeah
yeah okay it's a very lyrical piece
that's like I say when there's no
concept it's a lyrical lyrical animistic
so this big huge rock wall is actually
would I believe it
oh the illusions that we can create can
you believe this here in um here on 10th
Avenue Oh Moss doesn't it I'm gonna be
standing in the space and there's gonna
be about how many people 40 40 choir
members standing around me and I'm gonna
be singing up near this fortress or
castle is this a fortress or castle what
is it a fortress and a castle so this is
the model of the set it's like a
miniature of what the actual set is
supposed to be and I guess this is sort
of some sort of a castle or something in
here
I'm gonna be standing in here singing up
the sky
and I guess this area that we just
looked at I was inside there so that's
it I'm uncovering the myth here I've
just totally taken away the whole glamor
and illusion and the drama of this whole
thing by exposing it for what it is
yesterday was really fun you guys missed
it I was walking around in the dirt it
was so much fun
in bare feet it was really gross Riya
sang with a choir in the video and gave
et some acapella moments between takes
I definitely like integrating gospel
music into my music I mean in terms of
the vocal arrangements and the style of
singing that's something that it's just
a type of music that is really
inspirational for me so I like to try
and bring some of those elements into
what I do and sometimes also lyrically
I'll try to introduce uplifting ideas or
whatever into my songs
we don't officially know why this video
got shelved okay maybe that's why the
version that did get released features
Mariah with straight hair for the first
time in a music video
the official video is a lot simpler than
the original no castles no dirt just
Mariah and her choir singing in a house
her new look front and center
this reinvention of Mimi was a
significant pivot away from the
carefully crafted girl-next-door image
she had since her debut album I was
stuck wearing a turtleneck for the first
five years of my career I couldn't wait
to get that nonsense over with but
before she had total creative freedom et
was with the diva in training again in
1994 as she rehearsed for a performance
on Top of the Pops showing off that
straight hair
though mariah had eight number-one
singles in America by 1994 she was just
starting to break internationally with
her music Fox album this album was much
more like I had moderate success over
there with the first album really kind
of really great to have you know that
many people get to hear your music music
box went on to sell over 28 million
copies worldwide and by the time Orion's
next album daydream was released in
October 1995 she was in the director's
chair for fantasy it's not about like
whoa I want to be a director now and
like Here I am director woman it's just
to get the to get the result that I want
you know I mean I don't I don't care
about it from any other point of view
then I've never really been completely
satisfied with anything video wise that
I've done you know I've been happy with
things but it's like I'm always like oh
only we could have done it like this
Mariah went on to divorced Tommy Mottola
in 1997 reinvent her image again
[Music]
and she became the solo artist with the
most Billboard Hot 100 number-one
singles ever
but we'll always have our et memories of
the music video that never came to be
[Music]